je vous faire mon coup de gueule dans un
instant vous perdez rien pour attendre
surtout rester les eaux mais vous ne
faites pas de menace aujourd'hui sur
nombre d'animaux je suis la marraine
d'un éléphanteau on m'a demandé me
trouve un nom je l'appelais baba nos au
cas c'est peut-être en rapport avec la
trombe mais en tout cas la plus viable
le calcul de probabilités comme idéal
[Musique]
en 89 ou 90 je sais plus je suis triste
parce que je rentre de france et oui
18,5
[Applaudissements]
fm et ckoi se trouvait c'est pas elle
qui dit grosse bagnole petit peu je vous
jure c'est vrai j'ai acheté légalement
ça fait ma journée il y avait écrit deux
smic avec les cris de ceux myrtille très
sauvage ça veut dire quoi merci très
sauvage cct con comme un ballet 100
membres
eh ben mais c'était aussi les gens à
acheter en disant ça doit être super
frais alors complètement vous vous
faites votre entrée dans l'émission
quand
[Musique]
il a maintenant fabuleux mais j'en ai
six en bronze morphée
thiam envoyé un message dimanche et vous
laisse cavalli on a un quota lakota je
rappelle pour ceux qui nous éloignent
que quand elle dit panna cotta ça veut
dire qu'elle a fait l'amour avec son
mari vient d'envoyer panna cotta
dimanche matin il n'est dit chiche que
tu fais mais oui le tiramisu le soir on
mais c'était maintenant tu manque de
rythme quand tu parles je ris je t'adore
ce que je te demande si je suis riche
mais balawi moi ça m'a fait autant rire
que le jour où mon mari a acheté un
préservatif à tête de mickey en
allemagne parce qu'aucune flamme est
normalement c'est plus que mes manies
vente des préservatifs avec des packs de
personnages et même mari l'avait acheté
la tête de mickey ce nom
eh ben les fuit aucune femme normalement
constitué ne pas rire
la pénétration la tête de mickey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abbas
genre
non non je tombe tout le monde à sa
place à la limite c'est moi la plus
vieille la pub
[Applaudissements]